هناك ممكن هناك دوافع كثيره يعني كثير من
الاحداث والاشياء والبيانات والاعلانات
لها دوافع اخرى متنوعه غير الدافع
المقصود الظاهر في في العلل لكن هذه هذا
المثال وهذا النموذج الذي ذكرته هو جزء من
الازمه الفكريه الثقافيه التي نعاني منها
في العالم العربي انتوا كيف تحذر من عمل
انت لم يخرج الى العالم قبل يعني انت
افترضت يعني سوء النيه الان وخلت موقف
مسبق قبل ان يخرج هذا العمل وهذه هي
الاشكاليه الثقافيه في عالم العربي انا
اعيد اؤكد عنها اشكاليه ثقافيه لانها تغلف
بغلاف ديني فاحنا يجب ان نعيدها الى
الجانب الثقافي بمعنى هذا الحدث تاريخي من
حقي ان اروي روايه قصه تاريخيه عن هذا
الحدث ومن حق الجميع ان نتناقش حوله وناخذ
ما الذي دار حول هذا الشان لكن دعونا
نستمع اولا دعونا نقرا احداث التاريخ
دعونا ان نعرض اما ان يكون هناك حاله من
التحريض والترهيب
هذا هو جزء من ازمه الخطابات الطائفيه
الضخ
المتشنج
للرؤى الدينيه المنغلقه